[Music]
and you can't ever lose your history or
your stories otherwise you'll lose who
you
are it's the den way to pass on your
teachings to younger
[Music]
people
a lot has changed since the 50s and now
that we do have a say you know we're
we're going to make some
changes we want to take back our land we
want to be included in the decision-
making and make our community a
beautiful place I mean who wants to see
a big diesel generating plant soon as
you land in the front of the community
that's not
pretty no so you know things like that
need to
[Music]
change
guys can actually just can you guys just
stand in front of the book this way up
in the air hands up in the
air I'm the thigh Den n manager for for
the l k Den First Nation wait for
tomorrow I work with a lot of groups and
a lot of the young people that we hire
on as mutne youth
Guardians the whole intent and and plan
land for the KNE hunney Guardians is you
know they're Watchers of the land and so
the staff that we have on board have all
of the traditional knowledge skills and
uh training from our elders who have
passed on and their parents to live and
harvest off the land and to keep things
[Music]
[Applause]
protected
so you guys will just lead the way I
guess yeah go at a nice
[Music]
Pace what we're doing this week is we're
trying to develop a plan for some
walking trails incorporating Elders to
come with us on this trip you definitely
need some traditional knowledge to know
which path is the
safest and to get from A to B or to
where you want to
go big
fish that's the fastest fish I ever saw
I'm just being around here she knows
what the Guardians
do and I've been taking my dog
Serena she's been coming to meetings
with me and hopefully she picks up big
words hopefully she picks up something
when she grows up you know what I
[Music]
mean
all right so um here's the summary of uh
what we uh what we heard there's Trails
all over Trails have stories that needs
to be told Trails were mean to travel
there's a desire to hear these stories
from elders and to get them
documented
I mean what's the reasoning to have
Trails if it's not going to be us using
it know there's we should question that
first where's our Trail where's our
hunting areas they can't use that for
tourism definitely I like felt tension
when like during the meeting earlier we
don't know what's going to happen to our
future how we can make these two things
work together we have to keep in mind
that we want visitor
experience how many Elders had started
this whole thing the
TDN how many of the elders we have lost
since then I like to see the the youth
Carry
On The Traveling the hunting keeping
their cultural their traditional life
style we have a really really good
working relationship with Parks Canada
and the gnwt enr it's definitely a work
in progress and we're we're trying to
make sure that we have eyes everywhere
you know KNE Hut knee are Watchers of
the
land that needs to be uh
discussed in regards to
overlap land use I was uh involved right
from the
beginning to the day that uh National
Park Reserve was uh established and
signed and agreed upon the uh federal
government of Canada were the ones that
approach the First Nation back in
1970s 80s and '90s
asking if we were going to establish a
national
park there was disagreement because uh
we had no say in it the federal
government would be the ones in control
of that Park and we didn't want
that they had people out here and had
identified their traditional territory
as a very beautiful place but with the
stories that the Elders of that time had
heard there was some major concerns
about establishing a park back in those
days just because our people never ever
wanted to to seed or relinquish any of
our tree rates what is a national
park you feel comfortable that
you're PR rights are respected so years
and years had gone by they came back
they wanted to talk to another Chief and
that Chief basically said no if you're
not willing to give up and like start
saying that you'll respect our rights
we're not going to have a park in our
traditional territory so pack your maps
and
go I think with the new Canadian
government and the way that they've come
to terms with reconciliation with
indigenous people in Canada there is a
lot more respect a lot more willingness
to work together for a common
[Music]
goal this name was selected by the
community there's no other Park like
this that has been negotiated in this
fashion we as first nation's people
we've already kept this land pristine
and you know protected for thousands of
years and if we're going to continue to
do that in Partnership by creating a
park you know we have to be equal
[Music]
Partners hey let's go to Hole In The
Wall for
lunch
[Music]
yeah my grandparents like taught me how
to like live on the land and how to
hunt I remember coming here like around
2014 I wasn't like really paying
attention then again cuz like the not
appreciating the things like around you
as a
child you guys can eat without
potatoes us our potato is this kind of
stuff tast good
vitamins we always watch out for the the
the yellow stuff right here oh yeah
always watch don't break it you you
break it the fish don't taste
good and now like coming here again like
as a 19-year-old it's just it's really
phenomenal looking at it right
[Music]
now
in a
wall that's all
right I came back to because City Life
wasn't for me soon as I did that went
straight to B
school is kind of special like there's
no roads in and out we call it the
highway but we can go by sko by boat or
we can
fly
[Music]
I encourage people to come
to because us us in Guardians we're like
stewards of the land we're there to help
you not there kick you
out put your name where you from and
your inre
address just so we can keep track of you
you
know because his name is bear bear so
cute
you got her number anything wrong hold
up be there
[Music]
than I don't want this to change just
cck that I want to keep it the way it
is okay it's
videoing when she was younger I always
told her you know this is your land this
this is your
n look the waves are back Sarah come
swimming going to make her
feel she's you know going to she's going
to be proud to be who she
is to be able to pass on those teachings
to my son it makes me quite proud um not
only as a mother but as an indigenous
person from this community my door is
always open and I'm always willing to
help teach and and Mentor young people
and show them what I know knowing that
I've influenced them somehow or taught
them something that'll help them cherish
who they are as Den
people Generations before me have
suffered in the sense that we were
ashamed to be who we are as people but
as Den people you know we're
beautiful if my father was alive he'd be
so
proud yeah she's an
adopted and he took the point
of speaking to her taking her out and
doing all these things to what she is
today
yeah he'd be really
proud and they always wanted us to
protect the land to live off the land
this is home to us I've been traveling
all over the world world there's nothing
like home I tell
you it does not matter if there was an
old trail there you want the young
people to know one day maybe will go
over there and say this is where my
grandfather passed long time ago now I'm
going to tell you so that you can keep
it then when your kids are growing up
you can tell
them that will protect my
land not only mine but every body in
[Music]
care it's a indigenous lead indigenous
protected
area we're being asked to present this
model to be used by other indigenous
people in
Canada so it's something
[Music]
new
must CH to all my staff to the Cook to
our visitors to our elders to our youth
to our crazy dogs and then I guess my
question is to Terry what time is
breakfast w
punch it with your
hand it's very important that we start
bringing use with us because they're the
ones that's going to take care of it
right jump then I'll jump after
you no you go then I'll go I promise I
promise I go go go go go go this is for
our future this is for our kids this is
our our
backyard just going to have to teach the
younger kids and our people
about how to take care of the park how
to take care of th Den this is for
[Music]
them